hello everyone I was planning on showing
you a game played between Bobby Fischer
and Mikhail Botvinnik in the 1962
Olympics rooks Rock ending and it's well
it's quite boring for you know general
viewer I decided to show you another
game played in 1959 candidates
tournament play between Bobby Fischer
and Paul Benko this game is a lot more
interesting and quite instructive and in
addition I will tell you a very nice
story regarding Fisher and Botvinnik
from the 1962 Olympia a fracture to this
game so Fischer is white and Paul Danko
is black we have Fisher plays d4 d5
Knight to f3 knight c6 d 4 d takes d4
Knight takes d4 Knight f6 Knight c3 b6 -
Bishop to c4 Queen to b6 knight back T 2
G 6 Fischer castle Bishop to e6 Bishop
d7 Bishop to b3 black castle Fischer
place King to h1 Knight to a5 going for
that to LightSquared Bishop Bishop to g5
and now banco gets the idea that it's
going to play Quincy 5 he wants to put
the b-pawn and he wants to develop the
his light square Bishop to b7 so going
to c5 favorite place f4 and here banco
goes b5 fischer place a night to g3 and
here banco should have continued would
wish it to be 7 but banco plays b4 and
this move is the isn't as good as maybe
Bishop e7 and this allows Fischer to
play e5 and unfortunately for banco
White's attack is happening faster so D
takes on e5 and now Fischer plays Bishop
captures on f6 and Banco has to play G
takes and f6 if for example
Bishop captures an F
Fixodent Fisher has this nightly for
more attacking the bishop and after
Queen to e7 here's this tonight to h5
and this is terrible for black so after
Fisher captured on f6 banco plays the
gtex on f6 official place tonight the
CTE for Queen to d4 going for the Queen
exchange Fisher place nice Queen to h5
and in this position banco didn't
realize just in well how much poison
there was to this position and he played
Knight captures and b3 but this is
actually a terrible with a Fisher will
show future plays Queen to 8 6 e takes
on f4 to protect DF 6 4 and now nice the
h5 threatening checkmate on g7 so the
only way to stop checkmate is the push
f5 now the queen is protecting g7 and in
this position this is why I think this
game is extremely instructive for
example white can play Knight to f6 here
and after Bishop takes f6 Knight takes
f6 Queen takes f6 white will win blacks
Queen and as you can see white is a lot
better in this position and it's very
often that too when you have a better
position in the winning position it's
it's easy to blunder the game and even
though nice to f6 is still better for
white Fischer plays an even better move
Fischer plays rook a to d1 and you'll
see why this rook a to d1 is so
important for the rest of the game so he
attacked the Queen and the Queen has to
keep an eye on this f6 square so the
only move is Queen to e5 and only now if
it replaced Knight to f6 check which
should captures on f6 Knight captures on
f6
Queen captures on f6 and now Fischer
wins black screen and after Queen takes
on f6
you can see that this night is still
attacked so Benko moves the knight nice
a c5 but now you'll see why the rock on
d1 is so important facial place
g5 check moving the king out of the
defense of this ff8 rook and after King
to h8 he plays Queen to e7 and now he's
attacking both Brooke and the knight on
d5 and if this rook wasn't on d1 if this
rook stayed on a1 then black would seem
to play here Knight to d7 and he would
protect his Knight and his rook with his
Knight
so this is a nice Intermezzo which
simply finishes the game a lot faster
and well a nice game to learn from so
Ben could play a couple of more moves
Bishop to a 6-figure captured here and
after one more move Benko resigned and
well as as most of Fischer's games in
the Sicilian where Fischer is white a
very instructive game and now for the
story I promised you
after Fischer's the well poor
performance in the men's 62 tournament
in Cracow
it was the candidate the tournament from
a previous video that the frozen one
Fischer said that he would never play in
the candidates again or in any
tournament that was organized by fidei
and well Fischer said that he wants to
play Watson ik for a prize fund of
$2,000 and that he would give him a
handicap of two points so from the
beginning of the match it was two to
zero for Botvinnik and a couple of
months after well he said that he would
he got a chance to play against bots
Finnick in the 1962 india and he was a
very sure that he would win this game
and he played a spectacular game and he
won a pawn but the game was adjourned
and after the entire night both of them
were analyzing the next day when the
game was resumed but when he found this
nice trap and he managed to draw the
game so you can imagine the Fisher was
pissed Fisher was so angry and it's
interesting what Botvinnik said after
this game
botanic said that this draw against
Fisher is so much more sweeter to him
than his victory in the return
championship match against mistletoe and
like I said Fisher was extremely angry
and when he was given an interview they
asked him a couple of questions and one
of the questions was about what he
thought about women's chess and well
although Fisher never really cared for
women's chest maybe he was angry so he
said that he wanted to play nona
gaprindashvili the world women champion
given her a handicap of a knight and
this third really you know hard
reactions in the world and after death
asked Michael Tao what he thought about
this statement Fisher gave and taja said
that well
Fisher is Fisher by the night is a night
so I thought that would be an
interesting story and if you're still
interested in watching the game Fisher
against Botvinnik I will put it in the
description below so you can check it
out so yeah that's what the game I hope
you enjoyed it and see you soon